Jerusalem may 2007 befall what we
believe there's no doubt every day and
remains of hello to talk a who'd netzer
announces his team's discovery net sirs
confidence is absolute but without an
inscription bearing Herod's named the
team's evidence for his tomb is
circumstantial still their argument is
persuasive first the tomb and its three
sarcophagi are royal in quality the
ornate red one is likely Herod's who
once occupied the white sarcophagi may
never be known
second the complex in which the tomb was
found is the only one in Judea named
after Herod and we know from the
historian Josephus that Herod was buried
somewhere here third the red sarcophagus
was probably smashed on purpose perhaps
punishment for Herod who was despised by
his own subjects
new evidence from the sarcophagi and the
mausoleum platform make this possibility
almost irresistible
it shows the weathering of the building
stones is minimal signs of exposure
indicate that the burial monument stood
for just 60 or so years after that it
must have been destroyed and buried the
tool marks are still visible you you see
the hammers the chisels everything that
was used normally when a building stands
for a long time these two marks will
become less and less visible the fact
that they are so visible gives the
feeling that the building was not
standing for hundreds of years maybe 50
years maybe 60 years but not more
looking at what happened about 60 years
after Herod's death the timing is almost
perfect Herodium was then occupied by
Jewish rebels trying to drive Rome from
Judea and no one detested Herod's memory
more the rebels would have had the
motive to destroy Herod's tomb and would
likely have concentrated their anger on
the sarcophagus they knew or believed
was his the red most royal one
finally Herod was the only Judean worthy
of such a lavish burial about 60 years
before the demolition of the tomb took
place for netzer and his team it all
adds up